steven mme aubry fait la manche ici
quotidiennement samedi alors qu'il
s'installe comme d'habitude quelques
mots surligné de rouge le met hors de
lui
samedi j venu je me suis installé j'ai
vu qu'ils avaient eus papier dès que
jamais le papier j'ai pris le papier je
les digérer je les mêmes brûler j'ai
travaillé dessus je l'étais il ya
quelqu'un de la poste qui est venu qui
m'a dit ouais ça vous amuse de de
dégrader les papiers de la poste et où
j'ai parce que c'est vous qui l'avez mis
mais vous pouvez leur maître je vais le
refaire une affichette de papier imprimé
en couleurs a été scotché à la devanture
avec ce message il est interdit de
donner de l'argent aux sdf sous peine
d'amendé des mots qui ont fait le tour
de la toile quand le conseiller
municipal de saint denis majine
messaoudène relais une photo prise par
un de ses amis elle cette entreprise
dans de plus en plus à envoyer ses
missions s'agit qui s'arrête en
opérateur 100% publics tp par l'état et
deux contre nos vécus par les tabards on
paie pas de chasse aux eaux profondes
comme comme cela et c'est toujours sur
les réseaux sociaux que la direction
nationale de la poste dénonce
l'initiative la poste ne cautionne pas
le message affiché contraire à ses
valeurs et l'a immédiatement retiré une
enquête est en cours afin de déterminer
son origine
une affiche largement contestée par les
déversoirs pas pouvoir les aider quoi il
sera là grisons pas aux invités n'ont
pas à manger
c'est clair que c'est pas agréable pour
les gens qui travaillent ici ou même
pour les clients de la poste d'avoir
tout le temps des gens avec des chiens à
l'entrée de la poste
mais c'est peut-être le seul endroit où
ici ou où ils ont du monde qui leur
donne quelques pièces pour subvenir à
leurs besoins
ici on ne compte pas arrêter ni de
donner ni même d'être solidaire